[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis herzlich willkommen in
den nächsten knapp 20 minuten haben wir
wieder die nachrichten des tages für sie
und dabei auch sport mit norbert lehmann
eine signatur von mir als erstes aber
schauen wir auf den ukraine krieg
russland verschärft seine angriffe auf
städte in der ukraine
der westen dringt weiter auf eine
diplomatische lösung
währenddessen benötigen millionen
geflüchtete hilfe in der ukraine aber
auch in vielen anderen europäischen
ländern
und medaillen bei den paralympics die 15
jährige lin katzmaier und anna-lena
forster belohnen sich am vorletzten
wettkampftag mit gold
es war ein schwieriges gespräch so fasst
der elysée-palast das telefonat heute
von kanzler scholz und frankreichs
präsident makro mit kremlchef putin
zusammen bei dem sie ihn zu einem
sofortigen waffenstillstand und einer
friedlichen lösung des konfliktes
aufforderten bisher ohne erfolg die
gefechte gehen weiter wie christoph
distel und sarah laska berichten wie
deine stadt den ruinen wolfacher im
südosten nach zwei wochen straßenkampf
jetzt haben hier pro-russische
separatisten das sagen aber um welchen
preis überall tote nicht nur unter den
soldaten wie betäubt kommen die
einwohner aus ihren kellern hervor auch
irina die ihre bettlägerige mutter bei
den letzten angriffen allein in der
wohnung zurücklassen musste
ich ging raus zu einem soldaten und
sagte ihm dass meine mutter nach oben
ist er wollte mir helfen sie runter zu
bringen aber da war es schon zu spät wir
fanden sie tot
südlich von wollen nur wasser liegt
mario pohl seit tagen schon belagert
wird die stadt immer mehr zum sinnbild
für einen immer brutaleren krieg
panzer schießen den wohngebiete soldaten
im straßenkampf in den häusern und
bunkern verstecken sich die einwohner
ohne wasser ohne essen mehrere
hunderttausend sollen es noch sein jede
sekunde in lebensgefahr
alle frauen und kinder waren im keller
dann schlug eine granate ein wir waren
eingeschlossen und zwei kinder starben
keiner konnte sie retten der
stellvertretende bürgermeister hat wird
das grau nur eine erklärung
das dachten wir die russen wollen die
ukrainische armee besiegen aber jetzt
wird immer klarer sie wollen eine
ukraine ohne ukraine also töten sie
soviel einwohner wie sie können
das gebiet westlich von mario pohl ist
bereits weitgehend unter russischer
besatzung sollten die truppen auch
nicolai verhoben könnten sie besser vom
rest des landes abschneiden eine
millionenstadt der angriff auf mikko
live läuft auch ausländische
korrespondenten sind sich sicher dass
dabei auch ein krankenhaus mit einer
schule beschossen wurden
noch etwas anderes wird die ukrainische
seite den russischen besatzern vor
mitten im besetzten gebiet in milito
pohl sollen sie den bürgermeister als
geisel genommen haben
eine überwachungskamera zeigt offenbar
wie ivan fedorov abgeführt wird er habe
nicht mit den besatzern zusammenarbeiten
wollen heißt es am mittag versammeln
sich tausende einwohner fordern seine
freilassung das tut auch präsident see
lenski und dank gleichzeitig für dorf
und den demonstranten für ihren mut
jeden einzelnen bewundere ich für diese
art von widerstand die besatzer müssen
sehen dass sie fremde in unserem land
sind und wir sie hier nie akzeptieren
werden
doch die bombardieren immer mehr städte
im land jetzt auch lutz und iwano
frankiwsk im westen während die
bodentruppen weiter auf kiew zu rücken
nicht nur in den vororten der hauptstadt
stellt sich für jeden immer drängender
die frage bleiben oder gehen längst ist
allen klar es könnte eine entscheidung
über leben oder tod seien
die kämpfe zu beenden laufen weiter
diplomatische bemühungen katrin
eigendorf loca ine präsidenten lenski
schlägt dem russischen präsidenten putin
jetzt vor in jerusalem über ein
kriegsende zu verhandeln was verspricht
er sich davon
nun präsident zielinski ist natürlich
verzweifelt auf der suche nach einem
ehrlichen makler den beide seiten
akzeptieren können der draht zwischen
makro und scholz und putin scheint sehr
schwierig zu sein und sie lenski hat ja
bereits
ende februar schon mal gesagt dass er in
israel einen der wenigen demokratischen
staaten sieht die so wie sie sowohl
einen draht zu putin und zu russland
haben als auch zur ukraine salewski
selber ist ja jude und hat sehr enge
verbindungen nach israel und der
israelische premierminister
bertie wird ihm nachgesagt
hat ja auch eine große russisch
russische bevölkerung im land also davon
verspricht sich selensky einen makler zu
finden mit dem beide leben können wie
weit das jetzt wirklich realistisch ist
wissen wir nicht zu sagen auf jeden fall
wechsel druck natürlich mit den
katastrophalen entwicklungen hier am
boden jeden tag jetzt endlich zumindest
vielleicht eine kleine lösung finden zu
können deswegen wenn das zustande käme
wäre das natürlich ein fortschritt danke
für diese einschätzung hat ihn
eigentlich
angesichts der gefechte und
bombardierungen ist es schwierig
hilfsgüter zur bevölkerung zu bringen im
westukrainischen lemberg gibt es ein
großes logistikzentrum in das spenden
aus dem ausland gebracht und dann im
land verteilt werden wie das
funktioniert hat sich dara hassanzadeh
angeschaut
die lieferkette steht von polen bis in
die umkämpften gebiete der ukraine
lemberg ist der umschlagplatz die
hilfsorganisation sie die sie hat ihr
logistikzentrum in eine schule vor die
tore der stadt verlegt chaos in das
struktur gebracht werden muss
wir müssen die hilfsgüter sortieren und
danach nehmen wir die listen die uns die
partner aber auch das militär geschickt
haben dann werden die lkw beladen und
dann werden sie losgeschickt
stadtverwaltung notunterkünfte und
hospitäler aus der ganzen ukraine können
in diesem provisorischen logistikzentrum
sogar online bestellen geliefert werden
kann aber nur was zuvor gespendet wurde
und das ist noch immer der schwachpunkt
wie erfahren ausländischer spender
rechtzeitig was vor ort gebraucht wird
die schule von birte sie war schon immer
das zentrum für die schüler der region
sie kamen mir herum wurden ausgebildet
jetzt ist es das zentrum für die
humanitäre hilfe große lkw kommen an mit
den ladungen und es werden in windeseile
umgepackt und die fahrer verteilen es in
der gesamten ukraine
es mangelt an tarnnetzen und so nehmen
sie selbst dieser lkw soll hilfsgüter in
die umkämpfte stadt zu mir in der ost
ukraine bringen die fahrer sind
nachschub soldaten ihre routen führen
hauptsächlich über feldwege auf
diesen wegen werden also hilfsgüter in
der ukraine verteilt auch viele menschen
hier in deutschland haben bereits für
die bevölkerung in kriegsgebiete geld
gespendet allein über die zdf aktion
nothilfe ukraine sind bereits 95,7
millionen euro zusammengekommen thomas
münten zeigt ihnen wie mit dem geld
geholfen wird
das sind die ersten mit spendengeldern
vom deutschen roten kreuz finanzierten
hilfsgüter für die menschen in der
ukraine zwei konvois aus deutschland
sind schon angekommen zwei weitere sind
auch heute unterwegs
die hilfsgüter die das rote kreuz uns
zur verfügung gestellt hat werden an die
geflüchteten im ganzen land in ganz
polen verteilt aber sie werden auch
weitergeleitet an das ukrainische rote
kreuz
genauso verfährt auch unicef hier
treffen hilfslieferungen aus deutschland
für eine kinderklinik in lief ein
caritas international ist besonders an
den grenzen zwischen polen und der
ukraine wie hier in gudow mährisch aktiv
jeder gespendete euro wird auf die vier
am aktionsbündnis beteiligten
organisationen verteilt das deutsche
rote kreuz die katastrophenhilfe der
diakonie unicef und caritas
international
martin kessler ist der präsident des
aktionsbündnisses im moment gehen die
spenden so schnell wieder raus wie sie
reinkommen in der ukraine dass es da wo
wir uns natürlich auch alle versuchen zu
fokussieren wobei es am schwierigsten
ist ja werden warenhäuser die schon
existierten beispielsweise aufgefüllt
wieder es gibt also ein konto ist dir
einfahren in die ukraine dann natürlich
aus rom wo die ganzen flüchtlinge jetzt
auf treffen an den stellen auch in polen
werden beispielsweise 1000 plätze für
waisenhäuser geschaffen
solange der krieg nicht endet wird auch
der strom der menschen die vor der
gewalt flüchten und hilfe brauchen nicht
abreißen
und wenn sie den geflüchteten und den
menschen der ukraine helfen und spenden
wollen dann können sie das beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de
oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
mehr als zweieinhalb millionen menschen
sind nach un-angaben bereits aus der
ukraine geflohen zahlreiche nach
tschechien das land bittet daher jetzt
die eu um hilfe bei der aufnahme der
schutzsuchenden und auch nach
deutschland sind bisher mehr als 120.000
geflüchtete gekommen so
bundesinnenministerium phaser wie es mit
der unterbringung und verteilung der
menschen läuft zeigt sven regn sie haben
es fast geschafft olga und ihre familie
steht den dritten tag in folge an dieser
schlange vor der hamburger
ausländerbehörde sie wollen sich
registrieren dass es allerdings so lange
wartezeiten gibt das zerrt an den nerven
der familie aus der nähe von kiew
am besten miteinander
ja da ist es ist jetzt das wäre ja in
diesem schwank danach kommt meine mutter
geschaffene im
[Musik]
immerhin das amt hat heute und morgen
geöffnet trotzdem ist die behörde dem
ansturm der flüchtlinge nicht gewachsen
busse zum aufwärmen gibt es erst seit
zwei tagen toiletten und verpflegung
sind privat organisiert teilweise warten
hier 300 geflüchtete ukraine leider ist
sieht nach einem kaufhaus gibt keine
strategie es gibt keine organisatorische
hilfe viele flüchtlinge kommen noch mehr
und noch mehr dabei melden sich hier nur
die geflüchteten die schon eine
unterkunft haben die ohne
schlafmöglichkeit müssen sich an anderer
stelle registrieren gerade erst hat die
stadt 1000 betten in den messehallen
aufgebaut die aber sind schon jetzt
belegt die geschwindigkeit mit der sich
dann die zahlen hier auch nochmal nach
oben entwickelt haben die lassen ist
eigentlich kaum zu dass alle damit
befassten verwaltungsdienst stellen in
dieser geschwindigkeit
mitwachsen hamburg und andere großstädte
verhandeln jetzt mit den umlandgemeinden
dass dort flüchtlinge aufgenommen werden
können denn nach wie vor ist eines der
hauptprobleme das niemand sagen kann
wann wo wie viele geflüchtete aus der
ukraine staatliche hilfe in anspruch
nehmen wollen
für die geflüchtete hat auch das
kleinste nachbarland der ukraine die
republik moldau aufgenommen laut der
regierung sind rund 300.000 menschen aus
der ukraine bisher über die grenze nach
moldau geflohen mehr als 100.000 sind
dann auch in moldau geblieben eine sehr
große zahl für ein so kleines land
bundesaußenminister in bernburg ist
heute dort dabei versprach sie eine
luftbrücke deutschland wolle zweieinhalb
tausend menschen aufnehmen frank
buchwald berichtet
sie haben es erst mal geschafft
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine angekommen
am kontrollpunkt calanca im süden der
republik moldau
wir haben alles aufgegeben alles arbeit
schule kindergarten hier sind einfach
losgefahren aber was sollen wir auch
sonst
nun hausen sie bei eiseskälte in einem
camp an der grenze das kleine land
völlig überfordert
wir können 20.000 flüchtlinge aufnehmen
aber fünfmal so viele sind hier rund
300.000 sind aus der ukraine gekommen
wir brauchen hilfe aus europa
außenministerin baerbock heute in moldau
bietet unterstützung an deutschland will
zweieinhalb tausend menschen aufnehmen
anfang dafür sein dass wir mit anderen
ländern und zwar nicht nur in der
europäischen union sondern in anderen
ländern wegen ihr land und ihre
bevölkerung unterstützen hilfe die das
land und seine zweieinhalb millionen
einwohner dringend brauchen viele
flüchtlinge aber wollen ohnehin nicht
bleiben
wir haben überall schüsse gehört und
sind geflohen sobald wir konnten nun
gehen wir dahin wo der weg hinführt
wer verwandte in westeuropa hat will
irgendwie weiter reisen viele aber haben
ihre heimat verloren ihnen bleibt nichts
als verzweiflung
solidarität mit den menschen aus der
ukraine zeigen statt nur fassungslos
zuzusehen das wollten heute auch wieder
tausende menschen im ganzen land wie
hier in münchen zogen demonstrierende
durch die straßen und setzten ein
zeichen für den frieden der protest auf
dem königsplatz nur eine von vielen
veranstaltungen an diesem wochenende
mehr als 50 organisationen haben für
morgen zum aktionstag aufgerufen mit
großdemos in berlin hamburg leipzig
stuttgart und frankfurt am main
über alle entwicklungen zum krieg in
europa können sie sich auch umfassend
bei uns online informieren in der zdf
wollte app dort haben wir unter anderem
einen live blog und zahlreiche videos
und wir wechseln das thema
bundesfamilienministerin spiegel hat
vorwürfe bestritten wer dann nach der
flutkatastrophe im aartal sei sie vor
allem auf ihr politisches image bedacht
gewesen im untersuchungsausschuss des
mainzer landtages sagte spiegel für sie
sei die hilfe für die betroffenen von
höchster bedeutung gewesen die frühere
landesumweltministerin gab zu sms
nachrichten mit der vermutung verfasst
zu haben man könnte versuchen ihr eine
mitschuld an der katastrophe
zuzuschieben dies seien jedoch nur zwei
von tausenden nachrichten am tag danach
gewesen
die masken pflicht in deutschland soll
bald in vielen bereichen fallen wegen
der steigenden corona zahlen fordern
ärzte vertreter innen jetzt sie
beizubehalten
es wäre ein fehler dieses mittel ohne
not aus der hand zu geben sagte der
präsident der vereinigung für intensiv
und notfallmedizin magst der funke
mediengruppe das robert koch institut
meldet 237.000 86 neuinfektionen binnen
eines tages das sind 44
1876 mehr als vor einer woche
249 menschen starben innerhalb von 24
stunden
die sieben tage incident steigt auf
1.496
und nun kommt zum sport norbert uns den
beiden deutschen goldmedaillen bei der
panne das haben wir doch einfach mit der
grössten überraschung an die 15 jährige
lin katzmaier krönt ihre herausragenden
leistungen in peking mit dem sieg im
langlauf einzel rennen über 10 kilometer
ihre fünfte medaille bei diesen
paralympics die zweitjüngste athletin
dieser paralympics taktisch schon ganz
abgezockt in der zweiten rennhälfte
überholt die sehbeeinträchtigte
katzmaier mitglied florian baumann die
bis dahin vom laufen durch ivan ihr
vorsprung auf die chinesin im ziel fast
40 sekunden einen freudenhüpfer zu gold
für hlinka zweier und morgen eine
weitere chance auf edelmetall in der
langlauf-staffel
reinheit kilometer die runde macht spaß
da kann man noch erneuerung schroten
herum schroten und das zweite gold holte
die deutsche fahnenträgerin anna-lena
foster die mono ski fahren triumphierte
in ihrer lieblingsdisziplin dem slalom
mit
bestzeit in beiden slalom läufen sichert
sich anna-lena forster in peking ihre
viertel medaille mit zweimal gold und
zweimal silber ist die 26-jährige bei
diesen spielen die erfolgreichste
deutsche athletin
er fühlt sich einfach toll an das alles
erreicht haben im slalom der stehenden
klasse gewinnt anna maria riedler
überraschend die bronzemedaille
für die 22-jährige ist es bei ihrem
zweiten paralympics der erste
podiumsplatz
fabelhafter tag auch für die deutschen
biathletinnen beim weltcup in otepää
drei skijägerin unter den top sechs im
massenstartrennen und herausragend
denise herrmann auf platz zwei beim
letzten schießen haben vier frauen die
führung in diesem rennen vor augen
elvira ölberg ist als erster fertig
denise herrmann bleibt wie die
konkurrentinnen ebenfalls fehlerfrei die
schwedin ölberg setzt sich auf der
strecke entscheidend ab und gewinnt
diesen massenstart denise herrmann im
zielsprint gegen die norwegerinnen
reiseland mit platz zwei auf den plätzen
fünf und sechs mit preuß und folk zwei
weitere deutsche vierte podestplatz für
denise herrmann in dieser saison
in der fußball-bundesliga hat münchen in
hoffenheim zwei punkte liegen gelassen
die partie endete unentschieden hier die
bisherigen ergebnisse des 26 spieltages
gegen den fcb eins zu eins freiburg
besiegt wolfsburg knapp mit 3 2 union
berlin und stuttgart trennten sich 1 1
die begegnung augsburg gegen mainz ist
verlegt worden das abendspiel gladbach
gegen hertha morgen dann noch vier
sonntagsspiele ja deshalb ist der blick
auf die tabelle wirklich nur eine
momentaufnahme münchen vor dortmund
leverkusen dritter freiburg führte
hoffenheim rutscht auf platz fünf und am
tabellenende heim stuttgart und hertha
erst mal die plätze getauscht vor
schlusslicht führt und das abends spielt
gladbach gegen harte ausführlich bei uns
zu sehen aktuellen sportstudio 23 14
danke schön aber nach kurzem blick aufs
wetter ganz im westen kann es ein wenig
regnen sonst bleibt es trocken und oft
auch so nicht mehr zum wetter gleich von
katja horneffer christian sievers hat
das heute journal für sie um 21 45 waren
es gut
[Musik]
guten abend hohe wolken sind ja schon im
westen angekommen jetzt aber bekommt das
hoch ernsthafte konkurrenz durch das
tiefe donna del das bringt nämlich
endlich mal ein bisschen regen der ganze
märz war ja bisher völlig trocken das
hat interessante konsequenzen diese
konstellation denn morgen ist es hier im
östlichen mittelmeer mit null bis zehn
grad kälter als an der nordsee bei 10
bis 15 grad groß sind auch die
temperaturunterschiede in dieser nacht
bis auf milde sieben grad sinken die
werte am niederrhein in der oberpfalz
und in oberfranken geht es bis -8 grad
runter denn auch in der kommenden nacht
ist es wieder zwischen der ostseeküste
und dem alpenrand klar im westen gibt es
einige dichtere wolkenfelder und hier
richtung mosel sauerland und eifel kann
es auch ein bisschen tropfen das wird
aber wirklich nicht viel und auch der
regen der am morgen aus den wolken
herauskommt wird nicht viel werden
zwischen der nordseeküste und im
oberrhein sind die wolken auch mal etwas
dichter im osten strahlt dagegen wieder
die sonne der wind dazu kommt aus
östlichen bis südöstlichen richtungen
deswegen bleibt es auch in
ostdeutschland auch morgen eher kühl bei
9 bis 13 grad milder wird es dagegen am
alpenrand und dann rein bei bis zu 17
grad und am montag kann es dann im nord
westen etwas regnen am dienstag
überquert und ein regengebiet in der
mitte am mittwoch ist es schon wieder
für alle trocken schönes wochenende